what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in um let's get
started so first of all guys
you already know
the t-shirts are in okay get yourself a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt today guys
this fabric
So Soft okay and the best thing is you
wear these around and everyone comes up
to you and they say wow what an amazing
t-shirt I see your point of view I agree
get the get these women out of the
voting office men really are the gold
standard
women are maybe bronze and silver uh but
because you can't get a gold quality
woman you know
um it reminds me of my sponsor
noblegoldinvestments.com so the US has
lost 85 percent of its value since the
70s guys when the dollar decoupled from
gold which is why women shouldn't vote
okay all policies pass after women got
rights take them away okay and the
government
which caters to who women
um seems hell-bent on continuing this
tradition I bet I bet you I would put
money I would put goal yeah on that if
women didn't vote they would find a way
to get rid of this but it doesn't seem
like that's going to happen anytime soon
but support the movement okay so from
now on until the next elections the
government can print as much money as
they want the last time they did that
inflation went up nine percent and women
we can't do math we like cannot add so
yeah it's probably just gonna keep going
up however guys be smart be a man
um gold is one asset that has proven to
withstand inflation invest in gold with
Noble gold Investments you'll get a 24
carat quarter ounce gold standard coin
for free go to
noblegoldinvestments.com that's Noble
goldinvestments.com or simply dial
1-877-646-5347 it's the only gold
company that I trust one thing that I
think makes men
amazing and awesome is how funny they
are and there is a reason that we have
phrases like locker room talk men will
just be so blunt and just roast the [__]
out of each other and um recently that
we have a new UFC middleweight champ um
Sean Strickland he just won um and it's
we did a video like a month ago I think
it's coming out in the next like couple
weeks but yeah he just he just had a
really awesome upset where he he want I
don't know much about the UFC guys but
he he won and basically though
um this was so it was so inspirational
because literally everybody thought he
was gonna lose
um and yeah and then he came out on top
and now it's so funny because all these
clips of him were just going viral like
this man is the most
unfiltered dude on the internet so let's
play the clips every white person I've
ever met when I was a kid and I would
you know draw a swash cut my arm they
would be like [__] you nah man I want to
[__] you know try to kill him man and
get paid you were training with him so
does that make you his
[__]
I I've never smacked a woman but you're
about to call me would you like to learn
some Chinese
what was that way what am I saying what
am I saying
hello meow
I feel like I should already sir how do
I say work harder child
so when I started my clothing when I
started my clothing company and I opened
up a couple sweatshops how do I how do I
get to the meat and potatoes of work
harder no food for you till you finish
all right next question do you believe
fat shaming is okay if the person you're
fat shaming is someone you love
I think fat Shaman is always okay I
there's nothing worse than being next to
a fat smelly [__] and the most
human thing you could do is telling a
fat smelly [__] to put down the
fork well where do you think a win over
a boost would take you so here's the
thing guys I'm gonna speak straight with
you I always do I'm honest I try to be
you know unless I'm trying to sleep with
you I don't have to put big black things
in my face like this but we'll make it
happen I feel like you're used to it I
think you're used to it anyways how do
you think she got the Jon Jones
interview
everybody
and honestly okay so we have all of
these tweets that like
he's just like the most unfiltered man
on the planet it's so funny seeing all
of the red pill like all over his stuff
because I saw his women shouldn't vote
rant like I don't know a month or two
ago and I just thought it was hilarious
um so I I've been on I've been on this
wave but it's it's funny to see everyone
at the red pill like pick up on him
um okay so he says could you picture
being Jill Biden at a family dinner and
he said well Hunter I see you stopped
effing your brother's wife I'm really
proud of you also that sex tape you made
was very impressive anyways my rent is
coming any word on that payment from
China or Ukraine no and this is the
thing like there's so many times where
men will lose their jobs for talking
like this and what I love about the UFC
is it's like one of the few places where
guys can just talk
unfiltered without I mean they don't
seem to have the same consequence as
someone would have in Corporate America
you know I mean
what happened to The Wolf of Wall Street
type environment there's a reason guys
loved that movie now I'm not saying I
know they had like hookers at work
that's probably a bit a bit far you know
but but and that but that's what I mean
where I say like the the workplace used
to be a truly masculine place
um where people could talk freely and I
just think a lot of times women get in
here and we tell men how to talk and I'm
just really sick of I'm really sick of
seeing it in 2023 I mean we just whine
whine whine you're gonna notice this
trend guys of women getting into places
usually Elite liberal men giving us some
propaganda that gets in our ear or media
messaging but it's usually pushed by
Elite liberal men
one of the saddest things to me
is that
all of this liberalism and feminism has
infiltrated our churches you know
churches when you think about female and
male nature females are chaos men are
ordered and you used to go to a church
and you would it would be a true church
service and they would focus on the
scripture and what you see now is
churches adapting to the times and and
do you guys think that that's a good
thing for churches to adapt to the
culture or should the culture adapt to
the church
and I think that's where you can see
like throughout the test of time what
what is right and what is wrong and the
saddest thing is is there are clips that
come out like this
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
all right guys
what the [__] is that
oh I'm sorry I need to stop swearing I
said I would stop but this is like this
is the house of God
and I I get so irritated because the
conservatives will will act like this
isn't a problem or it's only Fringe
churches this is everywhere
um okay and this is what you're gonna
you're gonna see okay you go into these
modern churches
you're gonna see the young men under 40
are slowly leaving the majority of the
men are are young and naive and they
don't know any better or they're older
and married but you start to see the
young men drop out of churches
okay and you see just like on stage it's
mostly women and then it starts to be
more comforting
um it starts to be
more entertaining you start to see
emotional men and women adapt to the
culture
um put on a house of God shows like this
this is craziness guys and then you'll
see the women's groups come in where
they everyone Comforts each other
because they don't typically demonize
female sin and this is why I I harp so
much on men should demand virgins for
wives okay
because I have never heard a church say
hey
God can forgive your sin but men don't
have to I have never heard a church say
that I've never heard a church tell them
to avoid women with pasts even though
that's absolutely true but what I do
here is them telling women to avoid
toxic men and men that are just going to
use you but I never hear the same energy
for typically female sin I never hear
pastors talk about women not sleeping
with their husbands even though that's
very common in churches and now guys I
traveled to northern northern Wisconsin
right and I and I I ask people a lot of
questions and I you know I'm just I'm a
chit chatter right and I ask you know
just about you know and especially doing
what I do people just start to like open
up to you about relationships and a lot
of these men married the virgin women
that we talk about like the more
innocent didn't go to college like the
type of women you want to marry and
guess what the consensus is that the
reason that they're having marital
problems is because of the church and
the women's groups and the pastors that
Pander to them and we're gonna keep
seeing churches deny this act like it's
not a problem but this is a general
Trend across the board women get into
spaces you give them positions of power
and Women's Bible study leadership in
the churches altar girls and they start
to change the culture you cannot give
women power we just are not good with it
I don't know why
and this is why I harp so much and the
women shouldn't vote because when we get
power we just kind of ruin things you
can't tell me that's a serious church
service and and what you're going to see
is a lot of super emotional guys in the
church that are Clinging On to a fantasy
that doesn't really you know exist that
these these Church women are just I like
my question is whose fault is the
reputation of something and if if people
are leaving churches they're less
religious and they're in their General
consensuses but the women in church are
not better than the women out of church
why do we shame the people talking about
it instead of addressing the problem
why is the question oh well it's just
the churches you go to instead of saying
what is the problem here and I can I
could tell you guys the problem
um the church needs to start appealing
to men again instead of women
uh men tend to do the right thing women
just tend to do the wrong thing they
they need to do an active campaign to
get masculine men in church because
right now it's feminine men and women
because these are the men that tell the
women exactly what they want to hear and
until the church does an active campaign
to get men back into the church you're
going to keep seeing stuff like this and
single childless women in the church it
they almost make God these women's
husbands and it's really sad because
what are these women going to do in
their old age
um I mean there's a lot of things that
indicate Social Security is going to run
out a lot of these fallback programs for
women are going to run out so what's
going to happen to these women when they
get old
um and the issue is a lot of these
pastors and preachers get money from
single women they have a vested interest
in keeping women single I'm the nice one
guys I'm telling you I'm telling you
this is what they do I I argue it's a
depopulation agenda on top of like all
of these systems or just to keep men and
women apart
you know um and I could I could make so
much money just pandering to women I'm
gonna give you guys mine
my 30 seconds okay my 30 seconds Pearl's
just gonna Pander to women I'll say you
know
you know you just you really are not
you're really not appreciated you're not
you know and as women you know we really
just are not appreciated and we're not
valued and
um we really just need to start valuing
ourselves higher
and we just have this amazing feminine
energy that men just you know honestly
you have the power women
you are so special and different and you
cannot let men convince you that you are
not special do you see how easy this
[__] is
so easy
and guys like once you see it you can't
unsee this pandering and the simping God
it's so annoying so okay there is a
woman named Wimbledon Simona okay former
number one tennis player Simona Halep
has been handed a four-year ban from
competition by the international tennis
Integrity agency after being found
guilty of two intentional anti-doping
rule breaches including the use of one
prohibited substance rocks a dust at the
ruling which comes after a year-long
process could potentially enter career
at age 31 Halep supporters including her
former coach Darren chahil have
expressed doubt about her involvement in
doping While others in the tennis world
have criticized the delay in the
Judgment process and the need for
greater transparency hayla plans to
appeal the decision and is taking legal
action against the company she believes
is responsible for the supplement
contamination
I mean yeah this [__] is on steroids I
don't know what
like I I don't know really guys we're
like
I mean
I
I keep swearing guys I keep I
these stories just make me
but you know what's funny women we just
have this tendency to lie till we die I
don't know what it is men it's like if
they get caught
they're a lot more likely to kind of
just be like yeah
even with like you'll see these like
cheating videos come out and the women
will be like butt naked with the guy
still saying she didn't do it and the
men when they get caught they're kind of
like
they're like all right all right I did
it [__] caught me like they'll lie but
like once enough evidence comes they're
like okay
I wanna I wanna actually have a
conversation about another thing that I
loved and I I want to talk about the
pros and cons of women's sports because
this genuinely is a conversation okay I
I've played volleyball for 16 years I
love it I absolutely like it is
it's so fun and I I enjoy it to my core
okay and I'm gonna tell you some good
things that came with playing volleyball
made me a really hard worker
um it kept me in shape
um it's
it gave me a sense of community I've
made a lot of friends through volleyball
you know I I think there's a lot of
awesome people in it however we also
need to start talking about the cons
guys
and some of the cons is you spend
16 years of your life
um I trained about
between two to five hours a day
sometimes more I'm going to give you a
normal schedule so in college I would do
I think we would have train really
intense training sessions like three
days a week
um and that was that included like
lifting I could deadlift 300 pounds I
could squat 250 I could do a four minute
plank like these are these are just some
of the stuff in college I remember I
could do
um these were like really intense
workouts like you and and there would be
competitions a lot of fun
um it showed you to persevere work hard
um on top of that we had
um two to three hour practices
um
at night and a lot of times I would get
there early and I would train an extra
hour so I would really spend I would and
then there was film on top of that
um on top of that I also played
basketball so
um in high school I would go and I would
have a two hour basketball practice and
I would drive an hour and have a two
hour volleyball practice
um on top of that when I was in high
school you would do travel volleyball so
maybe twice a month I would be gone I'd
be in other states sometimes they even
go out of the country and this is I'm
not even saying it's necessarily a bad
thing there's pros and cons but I'll
tell you one con is that you kind of
wake up and you realize that you do have
this skill
um but it really is kind of useless the
rest of your life I mean you can go into
coaching which is a valid career path
but the thing is guys women's sports is
losing money and there's not really like
money at the end of it
um and a lot of women end up single and
childless that take it to to the extreme
and it also messes up your hormones like
that's why there's all these lesbians
and women's sports this stuff does mess
up your hormones and it's very tough to
balance like a family with this stuff
it's really tough to learn like
traditional skills be home for dinner
every night help your mom like you're
not you're not there for it
now you know we are in a modern world
and I will say it does keep you out of
trouble so I'm not even necessarily
saying it's a bad thing but I do think
it's worth the conversation weighing out
the pros and cons and is this something
that's you know good for younger women I
mean I could see both sides I do think
we're in a modern world and the other
alternative is a lot of these chicks
um I'll just you know it's like they're
in the club instead of Jim's better than
the club and I'll say that you know
Saturday night I was I was playing
volleyball pros and cons okay so
um Eric Khan had a tweet and it said she
had a breast reduction surgery to
advance her tennis career she also has
biceps most gym Bros would envy I
pointed out the Absurd lengths women
will go to become second-rate men and
Twitter lost its mind there's something
about being an athlete where you it's
like the feeling you get when you win a
really tough game and everyone comes up
and is just telling you how great you
play it or like you know I could think
of games where you know I
single-handedly like came in it was like
some of the best games I've ever played
we won as a team and they're like
amazing memories
um but it's like you start to see women
at like the high end of these Sports and
they just don't look well
um like does she look well to you
and a lot of times it's at the expense
of their fertility because a lot of
these chicks have fertility issues later
because honestly guys I just question if
we're really supposed to train like that
like I don't I don't know if we're
supposed to uh you know I'm super strong
you know and
I I'm you know maybe it's a little
hypocritical to think about this but you
know is is it normal for women to
deadlift this much and to squat this
much and and do this much is it is it
really healthy and I don't have all the
answers I'm not a doctor but I I think
it's I I think it's worth exploring the
question is what are the long-term
effects of women's sports and you know
on one hand we are in a post-marriage
society so I you know I mean what's the
alternative but
ah
I I think it is worth the question and
is it is it good for women overall
especially in Industry that they
subsidize because that's what I see this
trend is like they basically lead us to
be men and the industries they lead us
into ultimately a lot of times are
self-destructive
um but you know what isn't going to
destruct
gold so the US dollar has lost 85
percent of its value since the 70s when
the dollar decoupled from gold a female
policy a female women women just want I
mean think about it guys like we spend
our credit cards like it's water
um and look at the government it's gonna
keep doing this like you think the
government's gonna do the right thing
come on from now until the next election
the government really can print as much
money as it wants the last time they did
that inflation went up nine percent and
so that means one thing the security of
your future and your family is all in
your hands um so make sure you freeze
the value of your wealth so inflation
isn't stealing money from you invest in
gold with Noble gold Investments today
gold is the one asset that is proven to
withstand recession inflation and just
about all economic threats so Noble gold
Investments is here to help you if you
want to invest in gold you'll also get a
24 carat quarter ounce gold standard
coin or free go to
noblegoldinvestments.com now that's
noblegoldinvestments.com or simply call
1-877-646-5347 it's the only gold
company that I trust
um okay so our last story today
um is actually
about Troy Francis so Troy Francis has
been on the show a couple times
in a relationship but particularly when
you're in a domestic relief you know
it's funny though the one thing that
stops your testosterone from dropping in
those relationships do you know
get cheat on your girl Sensations I'm
just a scientist so Troy Francis has
been on the show a couple times and he
had a tweet today
um that really made
conservative and liberal Twitter go
crazy okay so
Troy says a high value man is a bachelor
in his 40s and 50s has a vasectomy Child
free by choice travels extensively uh
reads voraciously swims in the sea every
morning in sunshine enjoys the very best
of Life unfettered by the concerns and
responsibilities that others have so
here's an interesting thing guys okay
um I want to just point out how it's so
interesting when men get a vasectomy how
Twitter just gets so triggered and I
want to have an honest conversation
about this we know that the reputation
of marriage is bad okay
we know that women have a nature okay
we know that women's nature when we tend
to get power we aren't very nice with it
when we tend to get leverage we aren't
very nice with it uh my evidence for
this is in the last hundred years when
policy makers have had to cater to women
to get elected women have elected
politicians that have passed unfair
child support alimony divorce laws child
custody laws and really policies that in
my eyes only benefit women women's
nature is just very selfish I Can't Tell
You Why completely it's this way but I
see no evidence that it's any other way
now
does that mean every woman acts on her
nature no but the problem is we can't
have honest conversations about these
topics because everybody thinks their
woman is special and I've interviewed
many men that thought their women was
worse special when um they got married
and then they found out that she was
exactly the same and the truth of the
matter is that Instagram changes women
it gives us leverage to the point or at
least perceived leverage to the point
where we think we are better than the
men that are on our level and I don't I
don't think this can really be disputed
when you see women calling themselves
tens and let's look at the media when
women have been pandered to in the media
it's often at the expense of men when
women get power over men we're not very
nice with it
so the the reputation of marriage is bad
we can all agree on this so 50 roughly
please don't argue with me about five
percent okay fifty percent of marriages
fail all right now let's look at the
other 50 if the reputation of marriage
is bad that tells us that at least half
of the people that stayed married are
not in marriages that most people would
deem desirable and when you look at
numbers that go through
um I don't know
sexlessness when you look at numbers
that go through marital satisfaction
um we're looking at a 75 plus failure
rate of marriage
um yet
people can push marriage with no
pushback now I I don't say to get
married or to not get married what I try
to do is explain how these policies
affect everything right now the value of
women is lower and lower we're offering
less kids less Purity less youth
um we it's very on it's very rare to see
women actually serve men
um when uh you when you ask a question
to a couple typically you see the woman
answering instead of the man
um indicating that she's leading the
relationship
um instead of the guy when you look at
more traditional relationships you see
the woman looking to the man you see a
man being publicly disrespected you see
wives looking like [__] on Instagram
this is common and not every woman will
do it but we don't acknowledge women's
nature and we also see women that were
quote unquote good women and that did
things the right way let's let's say the
Steven Crowder thing they both waited
till they were married got married after
a couple months on both Christians and
it seemed like that was the right path
and yet women are women and when women
get leverage over men they're just not
very nice with it
and so what Troy does is
his version of a high value man right is
taking reproductive power into his own
hands you know ninety percent of women
have been on birth control and I know
women personally that are infertile
because of it yet you don't see the same
visceral reaction to women getting an
IUD to women taking the Depo shot to
women on the pill you don't see that but
whenever men take fertility into their
own hands we can't have an honest
conversation about it and you know Chad
Khan's will always sell marriage as kids
marriage and kids is the answer and you
know as a woman like I I want it to be
but I think when you have a 75 plus
failure rate it's disingenuous to say
just find a good woman and get married
um because women are still women and
even good women when tempted by the law
child support alimony the entire media
and culture telling you to leave your
marriage a lot of women are gonna take
them up on that and unfortunately
um we're we're really gonna keep seeing
a lot of divorce in my hand and my in my
mind or a lack of marriage
so now what you see is you see the Trad
cons just getting very pissed and and we
just we need to have an honest
conversation about it guys I've
interviewed so many men that are
absolutely worse off because they got
married this idea that marriage and kids
those men are are happier than the
others I I don't see it I see the
opposite I see men that are disrespected
in their own home I see men that are in
sexless marriages and I see the
occasional happy couple but I I see more
unhappy than happy and this is just me
being honest it's not what I want to see
but
um again with the reputation of marriage
being what it is I don't know how you
can argue with it
so
um this guy says married since my early
20s not snipped two kids with my wife
unfortunately unable to have more only
really travel to visit family mostly
reading parenting and theology books but
not as much as I'd like swim in my pool
a couple of times a week tired but
fulfilled and you know there's nothing
wrong with that either and that that's
what like you hope right but a hope
isn't what the numbers are telling us
and unfortunately you know
I I think the biggest mistake people
make is thinking they're special most
people are exactly the same most women
are exactly the same
now um I would strongly advise against
getting a vasectomy I met a bunch of
these type of expats in South America
the freedom of being a man is you can
start a family at any age agreed the
vasectomy part is a no no most high
value men would Delight in having
children at some point okay but guys I
want you I just want you to like think
about this so we know that men getting
married young and I'm not saying to get
a vasectomy this is what they're going
to say pearls push in for a vasectomy my
no my whole point is we can't have an
honest conversation about the pros and
cons of a decision okay so let's let's
think about this we know that met young
men have a hard time in dating so a lot
of men will come to the conclusion
um
I wanna I wanna wait till I'm older to
get married so I have a little more
leverage now there are guys that just
want to make sure they don't ever slip
up because the idea of them being
abstinent for 15 years if you want to
sell that to men good luck okay it's
like yeah you have to be abstinate until
you're 35. okay
um so a lot of guys just don't want to
take that risk now it's interesting
because the majority of vasectomies are
reversible
but the majority of marriages fail
so why is one
so triggering but the other is not and
if you say that's a bad idea you're
shamed
that's what I don't get
now
um this one guy says what is it with
these aging red pill homo see and this
is I'll tell you what's happening there
his world view is collapsing because
we've been sold the dream that kids like
if you kids are are the passage to
happiness and I would agree if they're
your kids but in the west the children
are not yours men have no legal rights
not really with their children women are
almost always going to be granted
custody women are the ones that are
going to put you on child support and
oftentimes women will be in the kid's
ear if it doesn't work out telling the
kids how awful you are and then now it's
like okay you have a 22 year old that
hates you is that better
uh and I'm not I I'm not saying that it
you can't have good children but the
idea like my question is why is one
so triggering but like we can't have an
honest conversation about it like why
can't you have a conversation about this
without
um going back to aging red pill homos
what is it with these aging red pill
homos trying to meme getting a vasectomy
as this great thing
um and again I'm not saying it's a great
thing I I think it's really I think the
real solution is changing
child custody laws I think the real
solution is changing marriage law I but
I think in the time being a vasectomy is
what some guys are going to choose all
right guys you know let me know what you
think guys get yourself a women's
shouldn't vote t-shirt you know I I know
a lot of you guys
are are saying I got other stuff I want
to spend my money on blah blah blah blah
guys guys it helps support the channel
right and then we can really start to
make waves on repealing the 19th you
know what I guys seriously and plus it's
actually hilarious all you got to do
people come up to you they're like
What's with your shirt and you just you
just look at them you're like dead
serious
and and I just have the same answer you
know we can't pick boyfriend
so why should we pick the leader of the
Free World I don't know it's fine get
yourself a t-shirt like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and let me know what you want me to
cover next time on another episode of
pearl daily I'll talk to you guys later